release the Kraken yes release the
Kraken recognizable by its massive size
and tentacled limbs the Kraken is one of
the most legendary and feared sea
monsters of the deep stories the Kraken
say it could take down whole ships grab
sailors off decks and create whirlpools
all to get humans into the water and
into the monsters waiting peak because
despite having more than half the
world's species to choose from for
dinner apparently there's nothing in the
ocean more delicious than humans I'm dr.
Emily xarna and this is monstrum
we know less about the oceans on our own
planet than we do about our solar system
and before we started going to space
sailing far away from land was just
about the scariest most uncertain trip a
person could take so much about the
ocean is inherently terrifying it's dark
vast deep and unpredictable it sparks
our imaginations of what could lie
beyond the horizon or what lurks beneath
the waves and that's where the Kraken
comes in the first written mention of
the colossal Seabees was by King
severa of Norway in 1180 he tells
sailors Swick out for a large squid like
monster that swims the coast of Norway
Greenland and Iceland since then the
Crockett has continuously appeared in
literature most famously in the works of
Jules Verne Victor Hugo and Alfred
Tennyson it's not surprising that we
first find his creature in northern
Europe given the reliance the Nordic
people had on the ocean for trade travel
and survival
unlike other sea monsters that require a
bit more imagination the idea of a giant
tentacled creatures prowling below the
surface of the water waiting to take
down unsuspecting ships and sailors
makes sense because there are living
organisms that fit the description - the
Sailor eating part the giant squid in
the colossal squid are two living
cephalopods that can be found in every
ocean on earth giant squid really are
giant measuring up to 43 feet in length
but the colossal squid holds the title
of the world's largest living in
vertebrae growing up to 49 feet long at
current record the largest one found so
far weighed over a thousand pounds
Oh in addition to suckers it has barbed
hooks on its tentacles and they are very
fast swimmers both species frequent the
deep cold waters of the ocean making it
hard to see them in their natural
habitat before the 21st century no
photographic evidence of a living giant
squid existed
it wasn't until 2006 that we first
caught these creatures alive on video
the Kraken is bigger than giant and
larger than colossal it's a sea beast
with multiple tentacles that often acts
aggressively towards humans a Kraken is
basically an angrier much larger version
of squid
personally I'm terrified of the crack in
something about those giant eyes
wiggling tentacles and suckers just
completely freaks me out and I'm not the
only one Victor Hugo apparently hated
anything with tentacles and is 1866
novel the toilers of the sea a character
has a frightening encounter with an
octopus who wraps itself around his body
and almost kills him
Hugo dedicates an entire chapter outside
of the plot to rant about how terrifying
and monstrous these quote devil fish are
writing about quote what ancient legends
call the Krakens he describes them as
gluttonous masses and downed with a
malignant will Hugo describes how such a
creature could wrap itself around a
swimmer and drown them it even goes as
far as to say that they are capable of
sucking blood with their tentacles he
summarizes his fear of suckers stating
quote claws are harmless compared with
the horrible action of these natural
cutting glasses the towns of the wild
East enter into your flesh with the
cephalopod it is you who enter into the
creature
yikes there are real accounts of
octopuses attacking and even drowning
swimmers many of which occur in the 19th
century the same time Hugo Tennyson and
Verne wrote their Kraken stories in
Verne's 20,000 leagues under the sea
captain nemo and his crew are attacked
by not just one but ten or twelve
horrible monsters described as giant
octopuses
it's a bloody inky chaotic fight scene
with tentacles flailing everywhere and
the crew defending itself with hatchets
and harpoons Edison's 1862 poem the
Kraken depicts the monster as an
apocalyptic force that will rise from
quote his ancient dreamless uninvaded
sleep one day to be seen by men and
angels the Kraken appears in nonfiction
literature as well with reports of giant
squid corpses beginning in the 14th
century we have the counts of mass of
tentacles washing ashore and of giant
squid corpses floating at sea
sperm whales are the natural predator of
giant squid so pieces of the creature
have been found in their stomachs and
they even sometimes get scars of huge
sucker marks from a squid that put up a
fight ok but how does that explain the
legends of Kraken
humans well octopuses have attack
swimmers and divers we have the footage
but there's another element at work
sharks we need to take these predators
into account when talking about the
Kraken those shark attacks are rare they
do happen often all witnesses would see
is a flailing body blood and maybe even
the victim dragged under the surface of
the water but no evidence of what was
causing the attack this established the
idea that large creatures in the ocean
posed a threat to humans
combine that with sightings of the alien
body of a giant squid or a large
tentacle and the Kraken legend begins to
take form
to quote Hugo these animals are indeed
phantoms as much as monsters they are
proved and yet improbable the Kraken is
unnerving because it resembles a real
animal sure we don't have conclusive
evidence of one over 50 feet long but
we've only measured about 500 giant
squid throughout recorded history we can
hardly call that a representative sample
of an entire species all we really have
are glimpses of a creature we don't
completely understand the relatively few
species we do know about in the deep
ocean are frightening because they seem
otherworldly we don't need to look to
space for aliens they exist right here
in the uncharted territories of Earth
even more bizarre creatures may exist in
the dark depths of our oceans inspiring
authors to craft even stranger more
terrifying sea monsters yeah yeah I'm
not gonna do plaid you can hold me to
that
so there severa you see what I mean
[Music]